هذا هو الميناء الشمالي بمدينه بورسودان
بولايه البحر الاحمر بشرق السودان هنا
تستمر عمليه الاجلاء لمئات من رعايه الدول
العربيه والاوروبيه والاسيويه التي بدات
من الخرطوم العاصمه برا الى شرق السودان
ومنها عبر البحر الى المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وبعدها يغادرون الى دولهم عمليه
الاجلاء تمضي تحت اشراف كامل من قبل الجيش
السوداني عبر مسارين بحري وجوي وكانت
العديد من الدول العربيه والاسيويه
والاوروبيه قد شرعت في التنسيق مع المملكه
العربيه السعوديه في الترتيب لاجلاء
رعاياها خلال الساعات الماضيه
في هذه المرحله من مراحل عمليه الاجلاء
التي بدات هنا في شرق السودان يتم الوصول
الى هذه المرحله وهي مرحله الاستوثاق من
الاوراق الثبوتيه ومن الجوازات هنا تقوم
الشرطه السودانيه ممثله في اداره الجوازات
والهجره بالتعرف على كافه الاوراق
الثبوتيه وجوازات السفر تمهيدا لنقله
واجلاهم عبر الباخره الى المملكه العربيه
السعوديه ومنها الى بقيه دولهم هنا
292 من رعايه دوله الهند بالسودان اكمل
اجراءات مغادرتهم واجلائهم من مدينه
بورسودان الى المملكه العربيه السعوديه
ومنها الى دولتهم فيما ينتظر اخرون
استكمال اجراءاتهم لمغادره البلاد خلال
الساعات المقبله نزار البغداوي لقناتي
العربيه والحدث الميناء الشمالي مدينه
بورسودان شرقي السودان لم
تابعه البرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقاري
ر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات